a political maneuver with potentially
far-reaching consequences
Iraq's president has sent his
resignation letter to Parliament saying
he would rather step down than approve a
new prime minister in a three-page
statement Barham Saleh said out of my
kinas to avoid bloodshed and protect
civil peace I will not name Assad ally
Donny as a candidate for the next prime
minister i donnie is the governor of
Basra province he was nominated for the
role by the largest bloc in Parliament
al banna that coalition is made up of
mainly Iranian backed political groups
which is why their candidate is being
fiercely rejected by their opponents
Ayane was picked to replace Adel Abdel
mati who resigned in November after
months of anti-government protests but
the governor has been accused of
neglecting his own province busser is
home to more than 70 percent of Iraq's
oil reserves but locals don't have the
basic necessities like clean water and
reliable electricity I don't think they
will accept his resignation I think they
will try to convince him is that you
must accept our candidate in way or
another but I don't think he will accept
that he will try hard also to push over
in just I say someone who is independent
transparent didn't be inside the
political process and look for the
future of Iraq protesters have strongly
rejected ID on his nomination and that's
the reason President Saleh gave for not
approving the choice it now means since
Mathies resignation no party has
proposed a candidate who has been
acceptable to all sides the protests
which began here in early October have
been about demanding political change in
Iraq and new electoral law was finally
passed on Tuesday which seemed to please
most Iraqis and now this latest move by
president Saleh to reject adonys
candidacy is likely to strengthen the
demonstrators position door such Aparri
al jazeera Baghdad